nous commençons la conférence de presse
les gens
ici est de la libye
mesdames et messieurs
nous sommes heureux de saluer à moscou
la délégation est bien joué dirigée par
mme en couches madame dhalla relance
gauche
la première femme dans l'histoire
je vais le poste de ministre des
affaires étrangères mine où le nissan à
la main se posera les jt depuis bien
comme steve nash et constatait que les
relations entre nos pays gros spoiler
robe dans l'histoire est bien
caractérisée par des relations
dépression caractérisée par des
relations de l'amitié au gommage de
recherche d'intérêt commun y passer les
intérêts de ce peuple et pour d'une
coopération
tant sur le plan bilatéral sur la
nationale ou d'où ils attendirent
walajah hominal gouttes ou al massalma
stars comme mister chop lima fait du mal
à
démarrer les discussions 10e j confirmé
cet
héritage qui se poursuit dans ses
relations
nous avons accordé une attention
particulière à la nécessité de reprendre
les projets économiques qui avaient été
suspendus il ya des médias disant cela
après l'agression commise se bat contre
la libye et d'ensemble des structures de
l'état et vous aimez contient de grande
importance à la reprise quand même et
jusqu'à 12h commission économique pour
le futur
au niveau interministériel avec les
grands deux entreprises audio chemins de
fer russes rzd
d'astronomie qui ont déjà travaillé sur
des projets présentant des intérêts pour
les deux parties
bien entendu les relations économiques
et commerciales
est reprise complètement sur la base des
pas positifs qui ont été entrepris à
partir de l'année dernière dans le
contexte de la poursuite du processus de
règle de règlement
et donc puis à cet accord de toutes les
institutions de l'état sur les plans
économique politique social
et aussi en matière de défense qui doit
se faire et se poursuivre
[Musique]
bin abdullah
mais nettement mali
le torride que
nous avons confirmé le soutien de la
fédération de russie aux décisions qui
sont prises dans le cadre du comité
politico militaire 5,5
et qui a été encore adopté il ya cinq
jours sur la nécessité du retrait de
tous les militaires étrangers du
territoire de la libye
il est bien nous ont informés
de la façon
avant ce les travaux
met en oeuvre
des accords sur le plan politique et ses
accords comprennent notamment la
préparation
des élections qui doivent se tenir fin
décembre de sept ans
[Musique]
nous sommes bien d'accord avec l'avis de
nos collègues libyens pour reprendre les
travaux sur la base législative pour que
le nouveau schéma politique puissent
être confirmés
nous sommes mis d'accord aussi sur la
nécessité de poursuivre nos contacts
entre les ministères des affaires
étrangères procéder à des échanges
d'opinions d'évaluation notamment sur la
question des conflits qui se
maintiennent au proche et au
moyen-orient donc ce dialogue est il que
nous avons entretenu les années
précédentes doit être repris et
poursuivi
[Musique]
je suis convaincu que la visite de
madame
main gauche qui dirige la délégation
libyenne permettra de donner une
impulsion tout à fait positive aux
discussions entre
nous pourrions mettre en place aussi des
contacts sur les plans humanitaire socio
culturel
[Musique]
et pourtant
je vous remercie
pour cette invitation pour cet accueil
chaleureux
je profite de l'occasion et de passer la
direction au gouvernement russe les
meilleurs souhaits du chef de
gouvernement appelait la famille de ce
bébé est aussi du chef
du conseil du gouvernement mohamed mais
ses salutations sont accompagnés par des
mots de reconnaissance
au ministre russe des affaires
étrangères et au président russe pour
les efforts de la poursuite d'une
règlement les biens
ce qui confirme ce que vient de dire mon
collègue je vous assure également que
notre réunion s'est tenue dans
l'atmosphère à 2 conviction qu'il est
nécessaire de continuer à promouvoir les
relations de l'intérêt mutuel entre nos
deux pays
nous apprécions le rôle russe
et sa contribution
à la réalisation du régime de cessez le
feu de 2021 et le rôle positif de votre
pays et pour trouver des débouchés
positive à berlin dans le cadre de la
conférence en question qui prévoyait
entre autres l'ouverture
de des liens jusqu'à misrata et syrte en
libye
dans le cadre de ses réunions
internationales nous nous avons pu être
d accord sur un nombre de sujets
[Musique]
dans le cadre de la réunion
d'aujourd'hui nous avons également
évoqué la nécessité de réanimer le
fonctionnement de notre travail sur les
accords entre deux pays portant sur
l'économie la sécurité et d'autres
sujets
nous apprécions également la position
ferme de la russie concernant sa
préparation de porter d'apporter sa
contribution
sur tous les fronts en cantine ce qui
concerne le comte calendrier du retrait
des formations militaires
étrangères depuis le territoire libyen
nous apprécions aussi l'aide de la
russie accordait à la libye à 1 ce qui
concerne la réunification de ces
structures de forces de l'ordre et la
restauration de son ou ses structures
étatiques
mais à mi oi
dans le cadre de pourparlers nous avons
évoqué la stabilisation dans le domaine
de sécurité et notamment à les accords
pratiques sur la mise en oeuvre des
décisions de la première conférence de
berlin à la crise
nous
nous sommes mis d'accord pour
intensifier notre coopération pratique
dans le cadre de nos ministères des
affaires étrangères et
notamment
du côté pratique il s'agit des projets
de la russie de rouvrir son ambassade à
tripoli et elle son consulat général à
bengazi je suis sûr que ces efforts
contribueront au développement de notre
coopération mutuellement avantageuse et
serviront des lampes pour augmenter nos
échanges commerciaux merci beaucoup
chers collègues c'est le moment pour vos
questions rachète day c'est à vous
bonjour mais sur la droite sa première
question est pour vous moscou est elle
prête à travailler avec le mouvement
taliban qui contrôlent presque
l'ensemble du territoire afghan pour
l'instant à quel point peut-on ensemble
avec des pays voisins contribuer à la
stabilité à la sécurité en afghanistan
et votre votre collègue j'ai aussi une
question sur permettait
comment voyez vous le rôle de moscow
dans le règlement complet en libye
surtout ceux concernant la sécurité et
le règlement politique à merci
une graine intérêts aussi à lyon
le
loisir avons aussi lancé
les camarades de
l'afghanistan aussi madaule gironde
l'état ministre affi afghanistan
libye
en
ce qui concerne la question sur
l'afghanistan premièrement les talibans
pour l'instant comme vous l'avez dit ne
contrôle pas l'ensemble du territoire de
l'afghanistan
il ya notamment des
informations concernant le panchir ou
une certaine résistance une certaine
résistance s'est
activée notamment avec le fils du
commandant massoud
mais je veux dire que notre position est
encore plus logique c'est à dire que
quand on a l'ensemble du pays qui a été
pris par la guerre civile de nous
prononcions pour la nécessité de passer
à un dialogue national avec
l'implication de toutes
les parties en conflit
sur les plans professionnel et
aujourd'hui les talibans
ou pris le pouvoir à kaboul et dans la
majorité des provinces et des villes
d'afghanistan nous continuons à nous
prononcer pour le dialogue national qui
permettra de trouver une façon
représentative
de
présenter les intérêts de la population
et la mise en place définitive d'un
d'une structure politique comment nous
voyons cela est bien c'est de la même
façon que ces dernières années
que de façon très active et avec eux la
truck a élargi avec les etats-unis la
chine le pakistan
c'est à dire que nous avons
encouragé un soutien extérieur
aux négociations qui doivent se tenir au
niveau
national
et donc les accords qui ont été conclus
la présidence afghane n'avait pas été
très actif pour mettre en oeuvre ces
accords on a vu il est arrivé ce qui
devait arriver
donc il ya un risque accru de
tentatives de résoudre la question par
la voie militaire mais en tout cas la
situation que nous observons aujourd'hui
qu'on ferme ans confirme encore une fois
la logique de notre position c'est à
dire qu'il faut apporter le soutien
autant que possible au dialogue national
en afghanistan et dans ce contexte suis
convaincu que le format de moscou de
discussion est celui qui a le plus de
perspectives dans la mesure où la
dimension est largement régionales ici
c'est à dire que les pays
frontaliers de l'afghanistan sont
concerne aussi et je rappelle que les
cinq pays d'asie centrale
avec la l'iran l'inde la chine le
pakistan les états unis et les parties
en conflit aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu
encore 2
deux propositions concrètes qui a été
fait mais en tout cas
les
toutous les participants en tout cas on
est était pour la tenue de ces
négociations nationales au niveau de
l'afghanistan et je pense qu'il faut
remettre à jour cette
structure de discussion
[Musique]
à
lille
4-3 solo je voudrais les trois quarts
l'allemand sur l'afghanistan huamines
ajoute arctique d'alexei koudrine
il est affreux
filles portant le foulard yar'adua libye
mais fidel castro c'est bizarre car s'il
est vrai qu'ils signent
famille à 12
one
day
without
libye
nous avons salué les déclarations de
talibans annonçant qu'ils voulaient
entamer un dialogue avec les autres
forces politiques en afghanistan ils ont
annoncé des discussions avec la
participation d'acs durable dollars le
représentant de l'assemblée avec hamid
karzaï l'ancien président est aussi avec
les représentants du parti du renouveau
de l'islam nous considérons que tous les
participants de ce gros
10 se sont dits prêts à discuter
participer à ce dialogue national et
nous allons encourager ce processus nous
allons faire en sorte que tout cela soit
mise en oeuvre concrètement
les relais les arcades de la bonne addai
l'estrade à doumbia mali est lui aussi
assis au bureau chaque alpha est la
ligue a fait le travail la famille haby
ma fille d'hulk abdel abd al
islah
islamiste cheikh maty enfin la bonne il
a empoché à la trappe à l'éthique
délicat
possible je vous remercie
aussi à
philippe
wahl adorent aussi
moussa a dit
la jeune fille moussa arrada fille bin
abdullah wade faible a dit
voilà c'est
aussi de loisirs la régie lavrov les
couleurs de offert à el jadida
les titres dont il est fait loi cheat
wiseid repas h au moulin l'idole des
philippines
je crois
je voudrais noter que la russie joue un
rôle notable c'est efficace pour assurer
la sécurité
en libye mais nous espérons que ce rôle
sera encore plus grands et importants y
compris
en ce qui concerne les efforts logique
la russie peau contribué aux rudiments
de tous les militaires étrangers depuis
le territoire libyen et pour créer des
structures unifiée et assurer la
structure étatique l'existence des
structures étatiques libyenne
ainsi que
règlement des questions économiques qui
contribueront à restaurer le pays nous
espérons que la russie qui joue un rôle
important sur l'arène internationale
pourrait profiter de son enfance
importante dans ce cadre positif d'une
manière utile et nous espérons que
avec
ce set ce guidage de monsieur le chef du
ministre le ministère des affaires
étrangères et se réalisera l'initiative
récente de consultation pour la
stabilisation en libye
kommersant s'il vous plaît
merci mariana belenkaya ma question est
pour une dame la ministre
qu'en est il de la mise en oeuvre des
accords sur le retire aux mains des
forces étrangères depuis la libye étant
donné que la turquie n'a pas envie de
d'en discuter et d'autres partis ne
reconnaissent pas leur présence en libye
merci
[Musique]
les
douze
régions
dans
lesquelles
merci beaucoup pour cette question nous
considérons comme très important le
sujet du retrait des militaires
étrangers des mercenaires étrangers
depuis le territoire libyen le
gouvernement considère cette question
comme l'une des priorités et sur
laquelle il faut trouver les solutions
les plus rapides dans le même temps nous
estimons que ce retrait ne peut se faire
que par étapes et d'une manière
synchronisée
pour cela il faut travailler sur les
mécanismes de la mise en oeuvre tous de
cela avant tout ses solutions là devrait
ne pas laisser se reproduire les sons de
certains de nos voisins ne pas donner
lieu en retrait
pas assez pesé des forces étrangères de
manière à ce qu pays se retrouve dans le
chaos et que
la sécurité nationale de la libye n'en
souffrent pas nous sommes ouverts à
mener un dialogue
c'est notre priorité c'est la tâche du
gouvernement libyen il nous sommes prêts
à continuer la coopération dans ce sens
je voudrais ajouter
je n'affirmerais pas que la russie
refusent parce que ce thème a été
discuté lors de la conférence de berlin
2 et cela est entérinée dans le document
final oui effectivement la turquie a
fait des déclarations d'affres et hâtive
mais en tous cas les décisions de la
conférence de berlin 2 n'ont pas été
changés et d'ailleurs le 15 août où le
14 août le comité militaire 5.5 a
confirmé le retrait de toutes les
formations armées étrangères quel que
soit leur statut
[Musique]
à l'époque quand il y avait des combats
une deux parties c'est à dire le
gouvernement de tripoli avait demandé
une aide militaire dans une région dans
une partie de la région
l'autre partie no - légitime à tobrouk
avait demandé une aide militaire
d'autres sources et grâce au fait que
sur le terrain un équilibre s'est
trouvée créer un équilibre militaire
c'est-à-dire entre les forces elle même
et les forces auxiliaires qui les
aidaient et grâce à l'existence de cet
équilibre nous avons pu parvenus nous
avons pu parvenir cessez le feu cessez
le feu qui se maintient encore
aujourd'hui
et le retrait de ses forces de libye
doit se faire et comme l'a rappelé la
madame la ministre il faut qu' il faut
que ce retrait se fasse uniformément et
en simultanément qu'il n'y ait pas de
déséquilibre le terrain et chercher à
extrapoler les discussions qui doivent
être menées sur ce point
madame la ministre nous a informés du
fait que le gouvernement libyen mais en
place un mécanisme consultatif
qui sera censé
mettre en place les paramètres concrets
de
liée au retrait des forces étrangères
sur le terrain et nous sommes prêts avec
les autres pays à participer à ces
discussions
[Musique]
je vous remercie